good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is SCP 163 object class
safe special containment procedures SCP
163 s enclosure consists of four
adjoining rooms three meters from floor
to ceiling with the following attributes
one five by five meter receiving room
with an airlock and seating appropriate
for both SCP 163 s and human morphology
one five by 3 meter storage room capable
of storing SCP 163 isolation suit tools
and games one 20 by 15 meter workshop
and dining area which contains all
salvaged technology including SCP 163 1
1 5 by 5 meters sleep area and rest
facility furnished with seating and
bedding fitting SCP 163 s morphology air
is filtered into the enclosure and is
automatically monitored at all times by
computer and wants daily by staff to
check for impurities filters are to be
changed weekly or anytime and purities
are found in the air two separate
lighting systems are used in the
enclosure one which produces radiation
between 400 Nm and 700 NM and one that
produces radiation between 150 NM and
300 Nm the primary lighting system is to
remain active at all times to facilitate
observation the secondary lighting
system may be turned on or off at SCP
163 s discretion
at no point are forbidden elements and
chemicals to be introduced into the
enclosure above prescribed proportions
listed in manual m163 1 personnel and
any items brought with them will be
checked for traces of these chemicals
prior to being allowed access to the
enclosure personnel are to wear
isolation suits at all times while in
the enclosure to protect themselves and
the CP 163 from cross contamination
before being granted clearance to enter
the enclosure personnel are to study
manual m163 2 and submit to an interview
with doctor cleared personnel are
permitted to interact with SCP 163 by
assisting it with repair off equipment
and by playing board games with it SCP
163 may leave its enclosure at any time
it must first announce its intent to
leave the enclosure through an
agreed-upon gesture and Dawn its
isolation suit the suit contains the
same air filters used to cycle the air
in the enclosure in order to facilitate
vision as CP 163 may carry a UV
flashlight capable of producing
radiation wavelengths of no less than
280 mm in order to keep risk of skin
cancer among personnel to a minimum when
roaming the facility SCP 163 is to be
accompanied by a junior researcher who
is to record all actions gestures and
expressions with a video camera the
escort is to also bar SCP 163 from any
areas deemed dangerous to it
once every three days personnel are to
deliver to the receiving room a 20 liter
container with chemical elements in
proportions listed in manual m163 1 as
CP 163 we'll take the container and pour
its contents into SCP 163 1 the empty
container is then placed into the
airlock or retrieval equipment may be
removed from the enclosure only when in
the presence of scp-162 if SCP 163
interferes with the removal of a piece
of equipment the item is to be placed
back in the area from which it was taken
at no point is SCP 163 1 to be
disassembled operated or removed by
personnel under any circumstances any
attempts to do so will result in severe
discipline description SCP 163 is a
sapient organism of extraterrestrial
origin when standing it is 2 metres tall
at 1.5 metres wide the bulk of the body
being suspended 50 centimeters from the
ground the Bonnie is roughly cylindrical
with a circular mouth at the bottom the
equivalent of a head at the top and 8 3
jointed legs arranged radially around
the equator as CP 163 also has a series
of specialised limbs and they are as
follows
two prehensile feeding apparatus on
either side of the mouth two arms near
the top of the body used for delicate
manipulation
to larger arms located closer to the
legs used for heavy manipulation and
lifting and capable of producing a
steady force or approximately 500
Newtons and a striking force of up to
2000 news 2 appendages of indeterminate
function located between the legs and
mouth parts which had been amputated
prior to SCP 163 s discovery 30
centimeters from the top of the body is
a single semi compound eye which extends
in a ring around it allowing a full 360
degrees of vision there is a blind spot
at the back of the head to make way for
an organ used for elimination of bodily
waste the compound eye is separated into
88 units the most likely hypothesis is
that each unit receives only vertical
information while the brain into its
horizontal information by comparing
input from different units the eye is
sensitive to light wavelengths between
150 and 300 Nm equivalent to UVC which
is harmful to most terrestrial life SCP
163 contains an endoskeleton which
consists of tissue similar in chemical
composition and structure to cellulose
the skeletal structure protrudes from
the uppermost joint of each leg and
appears to have been blunted by a
mechanical means no pain response is
exhibited when samples are taken from
these protrusions the skin is
transparent to visible wavelengths of
light but opaque to ultraviolet blood
samples taken have an oxygen and carbon
dioxide transport system based on nickel
rather than the iron or copper used by
terrestrial organisms and is green in
color analysis of blood and tissue shows
that SCP 163 cells use DNA for
instruction with a standard GCAT basis
however a different method is used to
interpret set instructions sets of 3
bases still code for amino acids but
they are not the same ones that are
coded for in terrestrial cells
in addition some terrestrial amino acids
are not present in its biology while
others that it uses are not present in
Earth's biosphere allowing for
dramatically different protein
arrangements SCP 163 s home environment
would have contained different
proportions of elements compared to that
of Earth this is evidenced by its
sensitivity to certain common elements
and its resistance to other less common
ones a heavy metal poisonous to
terrestrial life is used in SCP 163 s
metabolism iron and calcium though not
used by a CP 163 causes no harmful
effects to it exposure to in any
chemical form causes damage to tissue
and are as harmful to SCP 163 as they
are to us a full table of safe and
unsafe chemicals along with dietary
requirements is contained in manual m163
1 furthermore the atmosphere would have
had different proportions of gases SCP
163 is able to survive an hour
atmosphere for some time without
mechanical aid but will begin to show
signs of illness after one hour air that
is filtered to remove certain common
terrestrial elements will prevent such
an event analysis of scp-162 includes
searches for hermetically sealed
chambers which may contain evidence of
its home atmosphere it is unknown how a
CP 163 communicates complex ideas the
only vocalization produced by it is a
steady sinusoidal wave of approximately
15 Hertz when in certain emotional
states there is no variation to this
vocalization which can last from 15
seconds to 10 minutes it has recommended
that personnel exposed to the sound
remain in well lit conditions to prevent
feelings of paranoia emotions are
primarily displayed by the dome of
tissue above the compound eye
different states correspond to
distortion of furrows in the skin by
subdermal muscles in addition a negative
and affirmative gesture have been noted
an affirmative consists of the rapid
beating together of scp-162 threes
delicate manipulators while a negative
is the same gesture performed by heavy
manipulators specific information on
gestures and emotional states is
contained in manual m163
2 SCP 163 one appears to be a universal
life-support device it is able to
convert basic chemical elements into
sustenance for SCP 163 in addition to
originally projecting the phenomenon in
which SCP 163 was found to ensure
continued health of scp-162 3 study of
scp-162 3-1 is forbidden until after the
death of scp-162 3 the function of other
equipment is still not fully understood
the technology is limited to crude
transistors assembled into various
specialized analog computers many
physical processes that these computers
model do not correspond to anything
known to modern science it is theorized
that SCP 163 1 relies on some of these
processes in order to function
SCP 163 was first discovered by miners
in the Andes Mountains on 2000 the rock
strata in which it was found are
approximately years old
shocked minerals in the vicinity
indicate that it's spacecraft had
crash-landed the miners reported coming
across an impenetrable mirrored surface
which abruptly disappeared after enough
rock was removed from it the description
suggests that this is a larger version
of the phenomenon produced by SCP 163 1
despite being encased in stone forts
nears the contents of the chamber showed
no signs of age or degradation believed
to be an effect of the phenomenon
approximately 30 percent of the
equipment had been looted before agents
could reach the scene though some have
since been recovered
there are many items still at large
agents are continuing to scour the black
market for any further clues as to the
whereabouts of the missing technology
when agents took control of the scene
SCP 163 was still encased in the
reflective sphere produced by a CP 163 1
the relative simplicity of scp-162 3
one's interface allowed agents to
quickly deactivate it agents were forced
to subdue SCP 163 which was violent at
the time aside from this initial
confrontation SCP 163 has cooperated
with the foundation to the extent of its
ability to understand us
the following are select experiments
performed on SCP 163 a full list of
experiments and results is contained in
manual m163 - experiment log 163 46
facial recognition
date 2003 subject SCP 163 procedure dr
entered the enclosure of scp-162 3
carrying 30 11 by 17 cards with images
printed on them with UV absorbing inks
images were representations of human
faces of varying complexity SCP 163 was
shown these images from least complex a
smiley face to most complex a photograph
of dr.
details SCP 163 was not able to
recognize the smiley face which human
infants are able to immediately emulate
it was not until the 18th image that SCP
163 reacted by taking the card and
placing it over the front of dr. face
plate image 18 had exaggerated facial
features which included a nose eyes ears
and a mouth open showing a row of
straight teeth image 17 was identical
but with a closed mouth experiment log
163 47 facial recognition date 2000
subject SCP 163 procedure doctor entered
SCP 163 enclosure carrying 2011 by 17
cards with images printed on them with
UV absorbing inks images were
representations of the top of scp-162
aadhi ranging in complexity from an
isosceles triangle to a photograph of
scp-162 3 details SCP 163 did not
recognize the first card as a member of
its species the second card depicting an
isosceles triangle with a horizontal
line going through the middle elicited a
response SCP 163 took all of the cards
from dr. and looked at each in turn it
then sorted the cards into two stacks
one which contained 6 images including
image 1 and 1 which contained the
remainder including image 2 it is
hypothesized that the first stack
includes images which cannot be
recognized as a CP 163 species while the
second stack has images that can
the presence of the photograph in the
second stack supports this hypothesis
experiment log 16384 ism test date 2000
subject SCP 163 procedure doctor enter
the enclosure carrying two wooden blocks
and a box capable of holding both doctor
opened the box and moved one block into
it while feigning great effort after
closing the box doctor moved the second
block to ward it again feigning effort
and awaited a response from scp-162
details SCP 163 opened the box for
doctor after 10 seconds of him
attempting to place the block inside
while the lid was closed the result is
consistent with the same experiment
performed on human children experiment
log 163 88 higher functions date 2000
subject SCP 163 procedure doctor entered
the enclosure with a cart containing an
easel 5 canvases assorted brushes and a
selection of pigments which reflect
different ultraviolet frequencies
between 150 NM and 300
briefly demonstrated the act of painting
using three of the pigments before
handing the brush to SCP 163
details SCP 163 immediately began
painting with the provided pigments the
image produced was one of a landscape
containing unrecognizable plants and
animals according to UV imaging SCP 163
remains still for seven minutes after
completing the painting before knocking
it from its easel and retreating to a
corner of the receiving room cranial
ridges indicated distress all further
attempts at interacting with SCP 163
failed until doctor attempted to remove
the painting supplies from the enclosure
at that point SCP 163 s heavy
manipulators were protruded from between
its legs and indicated the negative
gesture the following day SCP 163 was
seen painting on a new canvas addendum
163 88 as of this date fresh canvasses
paints and brushes should be provided to
SCP 163 whenever its supplies begin to
go low this is the first truly
meaningful communication we have been
able to understand at the very least we
may be able to learn about the ecology
of its home world dr. Gordon addendum
163 93 the odds of scp-162 having been
discovered at all or mind-boggling given
the size of Earth a number of factors
would have had to come into play
including plate tectonics development of
terrain by humans and just plain old
dumb luck I'm filing a recommendation
that all excavations of it
year-old Strava be monitored by agents
for more members of scp-169 dit hard to
believe that we just happened to come
across one single spacecraft that
crash-landed on earth millions of years
ago at a time when we were just
beginning to develop the capacity to
recognize the importance of such a find
there must be others hidden and stasis
somewhere down there dr. P okay I think
that about does it for today thank you
all for listening if indeed you still
are and you were all dismissed
goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to Bob the reclusive extrovert GM's
Sabha arbiter soul Darius Tom Kareem l
oz Mui
Justin day o philia gray Thomas Morin
Curie kuma Aaron Peck and jayvo Jack dr.
crystal spice my archive curator Nick
Joseph Lewis ooh
agent vamp King modding and dr. Proctor
thank you all so much for your support
it's greatly appreciated if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos well on some other
cool stuff as well visit patreon.com
forward slash the volga thank you
you